we're a dog tied to a cart so the cart
is moving
and you can either like lay down and be
dragged
or uh you can sort of run alongside like
it's your call
and so the idea that like they're these
sort of
forces operating on us on the universe
that are far beyond us you know whether
you believe that's like sort of
god or the gods or just the logos
to me it kind of all gets you to the
same place which is
like you're along for the ride
even if you just believe in evolution
well that's a force that's way outside
your control that's acting on you
and humanity at this very moment so in
12-step groups they're like
like the second step is like accepting a
higher power
they're like we don't care what the
higher power is like it could be
anything just the point is like you have
to accept
that it's not you i believe that each
and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense
today on the show is ryan holiday he is
a writer
he has over eight books his most recent
one just came out
called lives of the stoics he is a
philosopher and i'm i just have such a
curiosity
for all things about life and to me when
you as i say philosophize um which he
did tell me as a real word
um you're basically contemplating
you're asking why and you're asking how
and so that's what we did in this
episode we talked about
life death what makes you happy why
people are the way they
are mommy and daddy issues i hope this
episode leaves you with
a greater curiosity for philosophy
and what it can add to your life i miss
traveling
i know i know i was just thinking about
like how how long it's been since i've
been inside an
airport oh really yeah
is it because you don't need to travel
or because you don't want to go to an
airport
uh well so so i we haven't traveled at
all because of the pandemic
and then uh so i i think
i don't think i've been in an airport
since march 8th
yeah that makes sense i mean it really
like it really happened right about then
because i was on a trip in peru
and um it was an emergency trip home
on the 12th it was like got there and
it's like ah
everything's fine don't even think about
what's going on and then the next day it
was like
oh so i don't know it seems like things
are happening something seems to be
popping up on my phone and then the day
after that was like
okay they might start to shut countries
down
and then the next day was like we have
to make that decision okay we're gonna
go back tomorrow and then it was like
middle of the night was
you have to be out of the country by 9
a.m or 10 a.m wow
and so it was like in the middle of the
night and you had to get up and
find a car in the middle of peru and you
know it was crazy but
um right i missed that i missed that
kind of travel i missed international
travel
yeah i know that's i was i was watching
a movie or something the other day and
they were like
on a beach somewhere and i was like wow
like i had like i was supposed to go to
all these different places over the next
six months and that just
didn't happen and it doesn't feel like
it's gonna go back to normal anytime
soon
why were you supposed to be going to
other countries just speaking like uh
just just talks for the book so i was i
had like australia
and then a like a tour through europe
and so i had like a bunch of stuff
um and uh
yeah we did one we did one road trip we
drove out to see my
my in-laws in southern california so
we've we've left the house one time in
six months so it's a little weird
do you have old family like are your are
your
like are your parents old my parents are
in their
60s uh but we have so we have two little
kids
i have one grandmother who's in like a
nursing home so we haven't been able to
see her but
uh but my kids i that like i'm totally
fine like as a writer this is like the
best thing that's ever happened to me
like i don't like
to do stuff so uh this is like like i
don't have to go to coffee i don't have
to go to meetings i don't have to
do anything so i'm i'm like uh i'm great
but we have like a four-year-old and a
one-year-old and so that we were like
they have not seen any people in six
months
this can't be good for them so we went
and saw in-laws but
so are you just kind of like a would you
say you're like a classic
writer um
yeah i think so i mean i'm def
definitely an introvert and
and like like they say like you're an
introvert extrovert based on whether you
get energy being around people or you
lose energy being around people
that's like the best test so like when
you like go to a con
because i think it's different when
you're performing like when i'm on stage
that's different
but i bet like when you're racing or
when you're you know in front of an
audience or
on a tv show or something that that's
that's not draining the same way but
like
if you went to a conference do you feel
like excited by that or
are you drained afterwards i'm very
drained oh no i get energized
all right so that's that's probably the
the difference introvert versus
extrovert but so but i
i've been also told that i'm an
introvert and i love being alone like i
have no problem being alone i
i like have all of my things that i do
and i'm happy to do them and
i have two dogs and i'm two kids but i
have two dogs and so i i know how to
be alone and it's really easy and great
and peaceful
but i i'm interested it's interesting in
the introvert extrovert because i get
really energized doing like speaking
engagements
um doing podcasts like doing like
engagement
on a deep level so right so because when
i'm on stage two i'm a really open
person so i really share
so i really like get going but if i have
to go do something monotonous
like sign autographs or small talk
is the death of me yeah yeah like a
cocktail party i hate
or like a nightclub i hate but if you
told me like
you me and five other people are gonna
have like a six hour dinner that sounds
like amazing
yes so i love philosophy
like i i don't even know if it's a word
but i love to philosophize
yeah of course that's a word is it yes
i mean i love it i i i literally have
dreams and aspirations
one day of this is like personal but one
day of finding someone that i can just
like
spend the rest of my life with that i
sit on the couch and we just like riff
on
some random topic or like a couple
random topics
i literally just told my friends this
last night um like that to me is so cool
because i just
i'm so bored by the monotonous and
the depth and like
spiraling off into all different
possibilities of like
how things could go is so interesting to
me
and so i heard you describe yourself as
intense and i
well actually i wrote a book called
pretty intense my podcast is called
pretty intense
i fee i i am like if people wonder
like people meet me and they're like wow
she seems kind of intense it's because i
am
yeah when did you know like when did you
know that about yourself
you know it's weird i don't i don't know
i do remember like several years ago
um it was sort of a it sort of hit me in
two ways so one
um someone had told me that they were
talking about me with someone else
and that that that that they were
talking about how intense i was it
didn't really occur to me
that other people were talking about me
when i wasn't around like for whatever
reason that didn't
that that struck me as weird and then it
was like
oh also what they think is that i'm
intense but
it makes sense because i tend to be very
committed to stuff very sort of
unswerving about it and then it's not
that i'm like
sort of blunt in like a cruel way but i
do i do tend to sort of say exactly what
i think
and if i think something's a bad idea
i'm gonna say it's a bad idea if i think
it's a good idea i'm gonna say it's a
good idea
i i don't like sort of dancing around
stuff if that's not necessary
and so i think you know we live in a
world where most people are kind of
apathetic most people just sort of go
along with things
uh you know most people uh don't
actually
like what they do and so they just sort
of do it for money or they do it
because they're good at it or whatever
and so i think when you find someone
who's
uh who knows what they want is good at
it
uh and believes in it that can
come off as very uh very strong
is it you were talking about like
dancing around things
and i relate to this so is it because
the truth just seems so obvious to you
definitely and and i think uh
because i i tend to have thought about
the things that i have opinions about i
think a lot of people are just sort of
winging it
um so like when i when i care about
something i actually do
i think one of the things that makes you
a writer is
you're like you're not good necessarily
like in
in an off-the-cuff conversation about
thing you really want to go like
figure it out you're like i had this
sort of vision of myself as a kid like
trying to convince my parents of
something or talk to them about
something
and then like not getting it so me
like saying to myself well i'm gonna go
to my room and and figure this out
and then you'll see do you know what i
mean like a like a sort of like
all you're not understanding me i'm not
figuring i
i'm not quite clear on what it is that i
think or want to say here
so i'm going to go like get it perfect
off by myself
you know like because that's what
writing is is like you have a thought
but it's like what is the perfect way to
express that thought
in a way that it's very hard to argue
against
and so that's kind of the that's kind of
the writing
that's the writer's mind i know you
i know you very i let me ask this
question
as part of more con i mean i obviously i
know you're smart and so this is part of
it but
are you very hard to sway
once you've made your decision
i think so there's a there's a great
expression i heard
um and i'm forgetting who said it but
they said strong opinions loosely held
so it's like i do tend to find what i
think
you know believe it emphatically express
it emphatically
but i i also think sticking to
something and not being able to change
your mind is is not super admirable so i
i think it's like you want to be
passionate and strong and clear about
what it is that you think
but then also realize that that that was
made based on a snapshot of information
and the information is always changing
so i do try to think
you know like politically i've changed
my mind on a bunch of things
personally i've changed my mind on a
bunch of things and and i tend to think
that someone who doesn't change their
mind very often
is probably uh that's probably more of a
vice than a virtue
what are some big things you've changed
your mind on i mean i grew up very
in a in a sort of a conservative
household so
you know i i was my parents were
republican that's sort of the beliefs
that i held
um and then obviously you know sort of
watching the world go the direction that
it's in i find a lot of these things to
be
sort of very alarming and and i mean
i've i
here here's the way i think about it i
think i'm less sort of politically
inclined like hey this is what
republicans believe
and this is what liberals believe or
whatever and think more about like
what is the in philosophy that we call
this going to first principles like what
is the
what is the core underlying
sort of fact or standard
and then being willing to change your
mind
uh you know if if issues shift or
or if fact shift but but actually you
haven't changed your mind
other people have changed you know what
i'm saying so like
i for instance uh my father was a police
officer so i grew up as a kid
obviously being very pro-police uh you
know
sort of hearing these things right there
and i generally am a person who would
support the police
and but at the same time when you see
you know what is clearly a a very real
issue in our society
you have to go wait i'm not like
pro-police or anti-police
i'm i'm pro-you know people's rights
being respected and provided that the
police do that i'm for it
and then the second that that that
obligation
is you know uh you know violated
then then i switched does that make
sense
yeah i mean as in my mind i'm thinking
to myself
um there's almost no set then
right when you're open it's like you're
permeable in every way and
you know it's kind of so what then
guides
your new belief system right if you if
you don't hold steadfast and true to
anything
forever then where
is the what like what are the pillars of
you like what
what are what what what guides your
belief system
no that that's i think that's the
ultimate question of philosophy
right like religion basically says hey
this is what god says you're allowed to
do or not do
right like this is sort of supernatural
law and and so
you know if you don't believe that or
you do believe that it doesn't really
matter
you could still see that what philosophy
is is essentially an attempt to answer
some of those same questions
but but not from a supernatural point of
view it's to
it's to sort of logically get down to
what's sort of right and wrong and
what you should do or shouldn't do so it
happens to be nice
stoicism which is a philosophy i think
about and write about
the core of the four virtues of stoicism
are actually the same as what in
christianity we call the cardinal
virtues
so so so for the stoics the four virtues
are courage
um moderation or self-discipline and
then
uh uh justice and wisdom so
so again to go back to this police thing
which i realize is probably
so incendiary that people who don't
agree aren't even listening but
like if you go oh the core thing here is
justice what is right what is fair
what is like sort of each human being's
you know uh inalienable
uh right and you know uh
what's our responsibility in that sense
the let's say the police brutality issue
becomes much clearer because you're not
going
oh i come from a police family oh i my
identity is tied up in me being a
republican and republicans believe this
on the issue
you're just looking at the facts and
you're going hey um
i find this to be repugnant uh and and
and evil and i'm making no judgments
about
you know the system as a whole but i am
i it is very clear to me that you know
x y and z needs to be done to prevent
things like this from happening
so so i think if if we say sort of
virtue
is those virtues are what's guiding you
then you know like think about courage
right courage is
a pretty clear concept and i was writing
about this this morning
um so there's this dialogue uh
between socrates and uh and and and
and this man and and socrates is saying
uh
i'm getting way nerdy for for you but
you said you like
oh i like it i'm sorry so so so socrates
is what is courage
and and he says endurance of this the
answer is endurance of the soul
and so you're like okay that makes sense
but then socrates goes
but what if you're enduring for the
wrong
thing or what if you're enduring because
you're foolish and you don't know
you know so so it does get really tricky
so i think
the idea is you kind of have these these
touchstones or these sort of
um big ideas and then the struggle as a
philosopher and as a
human being who's not trying to you know
be a
bad person is like how do you then
actually apply them in individual
situations
how do you uh you know a lot of
reflection a lot of thinking
a lot of soul searching but i i you know
what's weird is
is i think intuitively we often know
what the right thing is
but then what intervenes is like well is
this
good for me or not you know like it was
the intuitive the
is it intuitive what is intuit how does
intuitive play into stoicism
like how does it does it does it because
it's it's really like
it's sort of energetic right and does
that even play out
the the early stoics and what i love
about
western philosophy is just even though
thousands of years have passed and all
these things have changed
like they were still regular people and
so like
the analogy they they use all the time
is like
wrestling and boxing and javelin
throwing and archery
and it's like sort of at the outset
you know there is a lot of kind of
explicit training and you're
and you're um you know you're like okay
in this situation you do this and in
that situation you do that
there's a lot of rules but as you get
better and better at it as the training
sort of
comes into muscle memory and i'm sure
you experience this
you it it sort of gets into a deeper
level of consciousness where you kind of
just
know but you know what i mean like
you're not if you
if if somebody could have asked you in
the middle of your race
what are you doing right here what are
you thinking about i imagine a lot of
the times the answer is sort of like
nothing
like you've got you've gotten to a place
where you're completely sort of still
and locked in and you were operating on
almost a different plane of
consciousness
i actually have said that exact thing
that
so here's my example um about being in a
different state of consciousness i
truly believe this happens probably to
almost all athletes
um and maybe you could speak on that
because i know you speak to athletes and
you go speak for
you know to football teams and i'm not
sure
what else i've only heard football but
anyway you speak to teams and so
here's my example i was racing at
martinsville
a couple years ago when i'm still racing
and i was sick
and so i took some dayquil first thing
in the morning
and then i had breakfast and by time i
walked out the door of the bus
i was like whoa i feel drunk
like i was like oh [ __ ] like i've gotta
go drive martinsville which is this tiny
little half mile track
like slowing up speeding down circle
circle circle like you can get out and
feel dizzy almost from this track
and so i go and i go practice
i'm like top ten no problem feels super
easy
i don't even notice it in the car i get
out and
it's like i feel like my awareness for
things comes in really like
very um mundane simple kind of ways but
i was like man
i don't think that when we drive we're
actually operating
um consciously where we operate in our
waking everyday life
no you can't you can't be so i was i was
looking at this analysis of baseball
and they were saying that as basically
as the ball is leaving the pitcher's
hand
um the batter has to be swinging
so like the the the and it so so you
have about
400 milliseconds to decide
whether you're going to swing at a pitch
or not and so the idea that
the batter is sitting there thinking
about any of this is preposterous
it has to be operating at a at a much
deeper level because by the time
you could consciously go okay he's
throwing a curveball
and you know statistically here's what i
do
when you know like you can't possibly be
thinking at that level
because you know you have less than that
amount of time to do it
and so you know what we think when when
we look at the athlete
standing there at the plate we're going
oh you know he or she is great because
you know look at that look at their
their muscles or look at their form
or or you know you know they have this
quick tip
uh quick twitch fiber or this or that
we're actually
all those things matter to a certain
degree but but the strength and the
muscles are only
relevant after the ball has connected
with the bat and so
you know you see these big like honking
guys up there and
actually it's it's whatever allowed him
to make a snap decision in 400
milliseconds
that is the competitive advantage and so
we yeah we often sort of miss what's
actually happening there
so what is that then
i i mean i think i think it's well i
think it's uh
it's it's muscle memory it in the brain
being a muscle it's
patterns um you know it's experience so
so you're you're operating at this level
of knowing things that you don't even
actually explicitly know but your
question
really like sort of goes to this core
idea that
again plato and others were thinking
about thousands of years ago
which is like maybe there's some sort of
mystical spiritual element to it too
like
like here here's the question so like
i'm sitting
down to write where are these words
coming from
right like like how it just comes from
somewhere like
what the weird part for me is like so i
wrote this morning and then
this afternoon i'll either run swim or
bike
and inevitably at some point in that
i'll be thinking about whatever
and words will just sentences will just
come into my mind
and so i think you know in earlier times
we would have said this is like a gift
from god or this is
you know angels or or spirits or
something
and and i i don't totally know where i
come down on that i just
i just know that it's it's not operating
on a conscious level
and so um there's kind of a mystery to
that i mean but
one of plato's sort of paradoxes is like
it
ha how does scientific discovery work
like how do you know you're discovering
something
if it's never been found before like how
do you know
that you found it and so his you know
he's sort of saying like well maybe it's
because you knew it all along you just
didn't know that you knew it it's
it's a total mind [ __ ] do you believe
in reincarnation um
i don't necessarily believe in in
reincarnation but i do kind of believe
in this
um sort of passing of torches from
you know like generation to generation
so like
like um and i was just writing about
this too like you know
people will go like oh you know this is
a pandemic it's so awful
we can't survive we are descended
literally and
figuratively from people who have
survived
so much worse stuff right like when i
think about what my grandparents
went through two of my grandparents are
were first generation americans
they came here as refugees from europe
um you know i i think about
what what everyone who's
led up to this moment went through for
this moment to be possible
like of course we're we that sort of
spirit
is animating us in some way i feel like
um have you read cormac mccarthy's book
the road
no oh maybe you've seen the movie but
it's this
sort of post-apocalyptic uh
sort of novel about a young man and his
son kind of at the end
of the world it's like this sort of
dystopian hellscape and
it's really a [ __ ] up book to read
right now
but um here i actually have uh he um
this is the book let me get it
this is the book it's very good okay
i on on the shelf above me i keep on
like my favorite books but
anyways he he keeps talking to his son
he keeps talking to his son about
carrying the fire
and his point is that um you know like
our job is to carry the fire
like from sort of and and so the the
metaphor in the book is like the father
is
you know passing the fire on to the next
generation and the
the fire in the book is like goodness
right this is like this horrible world
where
you know everything has fallen to pieces
and you know it's like this
you know people are vicious and awful to
each other and he's talking about
carrying fire and
somebody sent me a lighter the other uh
not that long that just says carry the
fire but the idea
the idea being that that this is this
sort of
unbroken chain um
of of you know i i do believe in that
okay but that doesn't explain the
awareness it doesn't explain how you
know it doesn't explain where the words
come from
so the other thing that comes to mind is
if you believe in
cellular memory like ancestral cellular
memory that
is in you that maybe could make it
otherwise
it is the other thing i think of
is collect like a consciousness it's
it's
you know the idea that we're all one and
that you know i don't know how far down
the hippie road you go but
like akashic records as in like if
you can tap into sort of
energy everything that's ever happened
and will happen exists
as a frequency and so i don't know where
do you fall into any of that
no i i love that stuff and you might
think that the stoics would not be into
it
but you know like the stoics and the
epicureans two
2500 years ago basically were talking
about atoms like they had
some under rudimentary understanding of
atoms
and they you know obviously they talked
about sort of spirits and ancestors
the stoic the stokes have this concept
of sort of sympathia
which is this idea that we're all sort
of connected as part of this larger
this larger system that every person has
a role to play
and that this this does kind of believe
that these roles were assigned to us by
fate
so that's that's the other kind of thing
that i you know the stoics were
the stoics basically it's something they
believe so much in predetermination
but they kind of believed that like they
talk about this idea of the logos
um which in christianity appears in the
bible just means the word
uh or the way it's like kind of the
energy of the universe it's like
whatever god's will is that's what the
idea is so for the stoics
they were talking about um they were
they're their metaphor for the logos um
this comes
uh this comes from i think zeno zeno's
saying like
we're a dog tied to a cart so the cart
is moving
and you can either like lay down and be
dragged
or uh you can sort of run alongside like
it's your call
and so the idea that like they're these
sort of
forces operating on us on the universe
that are far beyond us you know whether
you believe that's like sort of
god or the gods or just the logos
to me it kind of all gets you to the
same place which is
like you're along for the ride
and and and so i kind of see that that
energy creeping into all things
do you believe that yeah yeah i do what
do you believe
no i believe in some version of that i
mean even
even if even if you're like totally uh
even if you just believe in evolution
well that's a force that's way outside
your control that's acting on you
and humanity at this very moment so i i
think
you know like in in in 12-step groups
they're like
but the second step is like accepting a
higher power
they're like we don't care what the
higher power is like it could be
anything
just the point is like you have to
accept that it's not
you and so that's kind of where i am
but you're an atheist right i'm not like
an atheist
i think when i was growing up i was an
atheist well when i was growing up i was
catholic
and then i i like a lot of uh i would
say
well i would say this is a like a lot of
uh
guys who think they're smart you end up
like reading richard dawkins or sam
harris and then you end up
you know like around college you kind of
become an atheist because
it seems so much smarter and you know
better than everyone else so i kind of
went through a phase there and i would
say as i've gotten older i've come more
towards a place of agnosticism
which is which is not that i it's
it's not that i don't think there is or
isn't a god it's that i don't know
you know like i just don't know and and
i think if there's
there's humil much more humility in that
position
than the assertion that you know that
kind of goes back to that whole like how
do you
what are your what are your core
beliefs that you hold steadfast to
you're still there in that wishy-washy
place right no no i think i think it's
the opposite of wishy-washy so
so um like he so
my this is this is my sort of take so i
think christianity is basically again
saying like do this don't do that you
know here's the word of god
accept it or don't accept it and then
you know the reward is heaven and the
punishment as hell
and i think the stoic philosophical
argument centering around a lot of the
same sort of do's and don'ts
but the argument is um if you
if you don't do these if you do these
things or you don't do the right things
you will live in hell so i don't i don't
believe in
necessarily an afterlife although i
again i don't know
i i'm not like hey the reason i'm trying
to be a good person the reason i don't
cheat on my wife or the reason i don't
murder people
is not because i am worried about going
to hell
i'm worried about the reality i would
inhabit
the person i would be if i did those
things so i have a very strong sense of
like
what i will do and won't do it
my my reason for it is
maybe a little bit my my i maybe i'm
having more of a foot in both camps so
in that in that sense maybe there's some
wishy-washiness
it's okay i think it's fun it makes for
way better conversations
um so do you believe in heaven and hell
then i don't
okay so you know about pascal's wager no
so pascal's wager is this is like 1500's
he's sort of very influenced by the
stoics um
sort of a brilliant clever guy but his
argument is that
um uh that
that to be a bad person is a really big
bet
because you don't know whether there's a
heaven or hell so you he's his argument
is
it's a safer bet to be a good person to
not sin
or or whatever because uh
because the upside is is very high and
the downside is also very high so it's
that's the way yes the potential of
heaven and hell is making it not worth
it
which still gets you to the same result
yeah that's that's that's the idea
so i'm sort of sort of there
so what makes someone a good person
versus a bad person
and we're using this super loosely like
right like obviously it's a sliding
scale in all kinds of ways but
you know i mean i've heard you describe
sort of like
having like mental discipline
and like spiritual bankruptcy right or
you know what
what kind of makes you smart versus
connected to your soul to you know the
feelings and
knowing where the words come from all of
that stuff like what
what kind of what leads you down those
paths
well that's the interesting thing about
stoicism right if stoicism is
is in some respects kind of the mastery
of your emotions the mastery of your
urges you know your your ability to have
sort of rational thought all these
things you could use those things to
just be a better bad person
right like you could it could make you
like a
better killing machine or something
right it could make you like a super
human
uh and and i don't i don't that just
doesn't strike me as winning
and i think the stoics would say like
when you really look at the lives of
people who are like that
you know it doesn't seem like they're
underneath the surface
not having a good time so so
i think that the purpose of the
philosophy is
is to be a good person that the sort of
someone bottom the highest good of
stoicism is
is virtue it's being good
what is what is that i mean we could
have a big discussion about it it's
complicated i think
marcus really is his line which i think
about he says the fruit of this life
is good character and works for the
common good
so that strikes me as a pretty good
definition of a good person and you
could probably
flip it and get a definition of a bad
person really easily which is
a person of low character sort of
morally ethically
you know um uh you know they're
unreliable they lie etc
and then are primarily motivated by
selfish ends
you know don't make the world a better
place don't help other
people um sort of see see the world as a
zero-sum game
so on and so forth how do they turn out
like that like how does someone do that
how does someone
live a life where you know you have the
extreme of murder and things like that
right but then you have
a lower scale of like not respecting
someone
and being selfish or you know it's again
it's a sliding scale but what
what kind of puts someone in in that
world where you know
they don't live a virtuous life like
you mean how do you wake up donald trump
yeah sure how do you how do you like
like how do you how do you wake up
and and you know sort of think
exclusively about yourself
you know sort of have no standards that
you adhere to no line you won't cross
you know how does that happen i mean i
think
like i think it's a couple things one i
mean at the core of it almost all these
people were failed by their parents in
some sort of profound
uh painful way um uh
and and then i i i also think though we
need to have empathy and go
do we not all have that inside us
and if if we've been instructed
differently or we've had different
experiences
might we have gone down a different path
so i try not to be sort of
super quick to judge in that sense but
but i think
i think what it what often is at the
core of these things
is a very intense valuing of the wrong
thing right so like um for athletes
right is
it are you valuing money
victory fame you know domination
those are traits that can serve you so
can certainly
serve you well in your profession just
that they serve you
they would serve me well in my
profession but but in
only in the shortest term sense of it
right and
and at enormous cost and and so
um i think we often i was uh i had um
new ginobili on my podcast uh this
morning actually and we were talking
about this and i was fascinated i was
like
okay like you know michael jordan has
won
seven or six seven rings i think six
and you've won uh four you know
is is there is the distinction between
those
two is it is it like did he just have
more of a killer instinct than you like
i was like when i'm around you i don't
feel like you're gonna rip my throat out
you know what i mean like
like is is that the distinction like is
there
is there like a level that you have to
go to to get to
and i'm fascinated by that because i'm
really driven in my career and i've been
successful in it but you always see like
somebody a little bit above you and i
think you can get you can
you can see that and go okay the way to
get there
is to do these things that i maybe know
or wrong
or i know hurt people or you can say
i'm going to focus this energy on the
craft of it
the love of it i'm going to feel
grateful for what i have and kind of
if it happens it happens sounds like ego
is the enemy
i mean it really does because it's short
you go taking care of the short term
and not the long term right it's gonna
make you feel good in the very moment so
then i wonder
to be honest you know
when you're doing wrong or when you're
do you
so do they really know
like if someone's doing that do they are
they actually consciously aware
how much of the time are these people
actually making decisions that they're
consciously aware
that they're doing wrong versus
operating from
this embedded
learned system that they earned from
their mom and dad because i a hundred
percent agree and this is with love that
every mom and dad is gonna screw up
their kid a little
you're gonna love them too much you're
gonna love them too little like there's
no
there's no you're not going to get out
of this alive as a parent without
having to have some empathy for yourself
because you're going to screw a kid up a
little bit
yeah of course i i think right
is the person sort of overtly or
deliberately doing wrong
or are they they getting what they are
they doing or getting what they think
they need
um and and i think that's that's uh
that's a question right is is trump
lying
or is trump just sort of intuitively
emotionally
uh almost incapable of telling the truth
uh about thing
and this isn't even political discussion
we're just saying like hey when
when he's saying this was the biggest
inauguration crowd in history
is that a lie or is that just coming
from a place of such
profound insecurity and sort of
um a need to always be better than
everyone else that it's almost
stronger than the truth and and so
i think it's both but to me that goes to
the point of
um the punishment for that person is not
oh this isn't going to work out for you
because it may work out for you
the punishment is in some cases
for some people getting everything that
you want right it's like
um would you trade places with that
person or you know like pick
pick whoever in your mind was like the
athlete or the competitor who embodied
all of the things that we're talking
about in a not good way
would you want to live in their head and
in their heart like
absolutely not and so i think that when
i'm saying like
hell is here on earth i think that's
that's where a lot of people choose to
live or or are forced to live
because of the the priorities that they
have
yeah that would be my belief system is
that heaven and hell
is on earth like it's not a destination
i remember asking someone a long time
ago i was like
so what do you think and this is when i
started getting really interested
years and years ago about you know i've
always been
i would call myself i think it's called
omnism where you
have a belief you probably know what it
is i don't know it's
a belief in all religions you don't
believe in any religion but that there's
truth in all of them
sure and so you know i i
very much got curious about you know the
how the how we operate as humans
and how we operate in a spiritual slash
religious way and and i
asked someone i said well what's heaven
and what's hell he said
well heaven's up and hell's down and i
was like
i have to break up with you it's just
that there was no
thought put to it and as i state clearly
stated at the beginning i'm
much more interested in the the thinking
of it so
um so i believe in that and so you know
then it makes you even wonder do they
even know
that they're living in hell and do they
do they know
yeah you know uh it's or if they don't
then are they
right right yes like is is the curse in
all of this self-awareness
and that some sometimes people are
protected by their own either
ignorance or self-absorption and in a
sense i really think that's what ego is
ego is this kind of
and we're not talking about the sort of
freudian or psychological ego but the
kind of colloquial ego
ego is really uh like a a
as they say this in a that's sort of a
conscious separation from that it's like
a bubble or a shield
and so to the outside world it often
looks like
confidence but it's actually coming from
a much more
vulnerable place and and that that it is
it is preventing you from experiencing
and feeling
because if it were to go away you would
feel really
awful and so i i think you know yeah
it's it's just
it's this kind of um we're going to go
away if if you're if the ego were to go
away or
yeah if the ego were to go away and that
self-awareness were to creep in
instead it's kind of like um like like
uh and when people go like oh but look
at all these successful people who
were egomaniacs or had big egos i sort
of go sure i'll give you a big list of
you know great musicians who are also
drug addicts like that the
that wasn't why they were a drug ad or
sorry the the drugs weren't why they
were great at music
and ultimately that the addiction ends
up often
killing the person but it's that the
drugs were a way
of not having to feel painful things
um that that that you know a sober
person would have to
to deal with and so i think ego
um and sometimes just you know whatever
these things we get obsessed with like
you know i think for driven people and
maybe you felt this way
you know you feel like you feel like
when i get there when i get to the top
of the mountain like when you when i
sell this many books or i win this award
or i
you know i you know it's like hey when i
win you know my first race and then when
i get
you know then when i have three of them
then when i have the best season of all
time like
you tell yourself like it's this thing
and once i get this thing then i won't
feel this way anymore
and that's just um you know you can see
why from an evolutionary standpoint
that's a very
productive delusion but it's
you know it doesn't make anyone happy in
the end yeah
i've suffered from a little destination
syndrome for sure in different ways both
professionally and personally probably
especially personally
to be honest i'm a lot more disconnected
from the outcome with
professional than i am with personal
which is probably why that one's been
successful and the other one hasn't been
as successful
you mean like when i meet the right
person or that kind of yeah
yeah they're gonna take care of
everything's gonna be great and
you know they'll will support each other
and you know
yet i you know resided in a little
codependency then and so you know
so is feeling
criteria to
not be in your ego then feeling emotions
feeling feeling pain feeling deep things
feeling
sadness feeling is feeling part of the
barometer
that's a i haven't thought about that
yeah sure i think
ego is almost inherently an unfeeling
place or
it's it's just complete self-absorption
at the expense of all
other uh feelings particularly and and
most commonly
you know the the feeling of of uh
of empathy you know giving a [ __ ] about
other people
um well they say that like narcissists
lack empathy like that's one of sort of
like the core
core uh qualities about a narcissist is
that they just
can't feel yeah and and and by the way
that's why
when i write about ego why it's so
dangerous in the arts or in like
in music or in writing or in business um
is because what you're doing
inherently requires empathy
or else it won't work for anyone like if
you're making a song that's
if you're like writing a song and you
have your head so far up your own ass
that you can't conceive of anyone else's
reality that
that song is going to be meaningless
right like if i'm sitting and writing a
book and i'm
so obsessed with my own pain and my own
issues and my own stuff
i'm not gonna it's not gonna land
because it's it's
for an audience of one and so i i do
think empathy is that core
i was i was rereading meditations
and you know you read you read things
many many times and sometimes
you miss something that was right there
um the the whole time let me actually
you know let me see if i find it
um i might find the whole passage he uh
this is so marcus aurelius begins
meditations like really incredibly
with like a list of all the things that
he learned from other people
which i love like so much like that's
such an incredible thing
for the most powerful man in the world
to do uh where's sextus
um by the way here's the whole this
whole section is on the gods
what he learned from the gods where is
sextus
uh he says um uh
not to display anger or other emotions
to be free of passion yet full of love
and uh that that quote just hit me
really hard
a couple weeks ago and i've been
thinking about it a lot since
so like we we think of stoicism as the
absence of emotion
and that you know it means you're not
angry you're not sad you don't grieve
you don't
lust you don't care and i think that's
totally wrong
i think he's saying you're stripping out
the other emotions and you're replacing
it
with what we were just talking about
which is empathy and compassion and
care for other people how is that
different
well how does so stripping away so
isn't that part of feeling like empathy
and all that stuff like what are you
stripping away to get that
i i you're you're you're stripping away
the the
the other emotions that are not that so
you're stripping away
anger and you're you're stripping away
fear and you're stripping away
and envy and you're stripping away your
reaction
then so you're sweeping away the
reaction reactionary feelings as opposed
to
i think what i'm saying is we tend to
think of stoicism as
as being unfeeling and i think that
that he's saying that it's no it's not
being unfeeling
it's about feeling the the right and the
most important thing
which is this which is he's saying sort
of being full of love and
and so and your point about all
religions being
the same i do i do think at the core
it is about that idea of love
how do we get there uh yeah i mean if i
knew
if i knew that um i i don't know what
i'd be doing
but uh i think i think this is a lot of
work i mean what what i what what i
think is so
incredible about meditations for
instance
which is sort of the book that i you
know
spend most of my time thinking about and
writing about is
here you have i mean he's writing this
well
into his reign as the most powerful man
in the world
and so he's spending his time like he's
carving out
space in the morning or maybe he's
carving out space before bed
or he's you know setting aside a few
minutes despite all the things that are
you know all the demands on his time and
he's he's using that to
to just like sit and think and reflect
and write in a journal
there's another so sextus the
philosopher that marcus is talking about
there's this great anecdote about marcus
where you know he's again he's
well inches ran his emperor and he just
come back to rome
from you know time uh uh on the on
on the frontier and and uh you know he's
leaving he's leaving his palace and one
of his friends sees him and he says
you know um where are you going uh and
he says
i am i'm going to see sexist the
philosopher
to learn what i what i do not yet know
and so
the idea that even in old age he was
focused on
learning on on getting better
to me is the idea like wisdom isn't this
thing that you just
get like you get wisdom like a college
degree
but that philosophy is this kind of
lifelong
practice and pursuit that we have to be
continually engaged in
um just in the way that nobody thinks
like oh
i went to church once i am a christian
it's
like no it's a ritual and it's a routine
and it's a practice and it's
it's a it's a process of the things
really sinking into your heart and your
soul
what makes someone
interested in philosophy versus
not well i would say the vast vast vast
majority
maybe that's the right word not
interested but open right because i
think that's a different thing because
philosophy to me is the
ability to change your mind right
there's almost
yeah i mean like we've been talking
about that a lot but its philosophy is
the ability to listen
and speak and vet through things and
you know what makes someone open to
philosophy versus
totally against it well i think one of
the one of the
tragedies of our time is that we have
come to present
philosophy to people as
this kind of abstract theoretical thing
like i was talking to a
person the other day and he mentioned he
was like you know nyu has the the best
philosophy
department in the world and i was like
i don't think i was like i write about
philosophy
professionally and i cannot tell you the
name of one philosopher at nyu
um the point being philosophy doesn't
exist
in any form that's remotely accessible
or usable to real people
and and that's a to me a tremendous
shame and a perversion of what
philosophy was for thousands of years
like seneca he says you know do you want
to know what philosophy offers the world
and he says philosophy offers counsel
and
philosophy is like a helping hand it's a
shoulder to lean on it's
advice and and again it's this grand
tradition of people
struggling with these questions over and
over again and
you know making a tiny bit of progress
so i think
what i try to do in my writing is
present philosophy as something that
people could be open to so
like with the obstacle is the way which
is my first book about stoicism
basically
my thinking was people nobody wakes up
and says
i need more philosophy they tend to wake
up and say
i have these problems that i need help
solving and so i try to present
philosophy as a solution to our problems
and
and marx really talks about this in
meditation says make sure that you see
philosophy as a balm
as a soothing ointment um and and
and so i think if if people understood
that that's what you could get out of it
i think everyone would be reading it
just in the way that it took generations
for people to realize like oh
therapy is something you don't have to
be like mentally ill to
benefit from therapy and i think you
don't have to be a genius to benefit
from philosophy it's it's
designed to help you with what you're
going through
i feel like philosophy almost has like
an inheritance inherent
balance to it would you would you agree
yeah yes yes um and look that again
we're talking about the four virtues so
it's courage
but moderation is one of them and so
that idea of balance
and the like aristotle says the hardest
thing in the world is to find
like the right amount at the right time
you know in the right per you know it
that
that it's it's easy to kind of know
you know what what you should do but but
or what the solution is but the amount
of ingredients or the the right
application at the right time in the
right way
that's that's the really really tricky
part
it's like i feel like i'm thinking about
going back to parents
right like that exact perfect amount at
exact
right time and you know you've got
discipline and then you've got
you know commending your child and
you know all kinds of things that have
to be in perfect balance all the time
and so
you know another thing that i was
thinking about was you know you're
talking about meditation we're talking
about balance
so and then there's all these different
disciplines of courage and
and and all of the the four what do you
call them the four
the four virtues for virtues for virtues
um
so is stillness like
the balance of all disciplines
i i think so i would i would maybe argue
that stillness is the place you
get to when you put in the work
so just like um you know just like
an athlete sort of perfectly trained and
timed for the moment
is going to be much calmer and stiller
you know in the fourth quarter than the
athlete who is
horribly unprepared and and and not
ready for that moment
and so i think stillness is like what
you get
when you strip away the things that are
inessential and you
focus on what is essential so i mean
look there's the stillness of like hey
i'm sitting on a porch swing
you know on a summer evening in the
south and that's wonderful or you know
stillness is a beach in the in hawaii
or you know whatever but stillness to me
is also
um the sort of the apotheosis of
all the all the work it's like being but
that flow state you're talking about
where
the idea that you could even be sort of
still
and locked in when you're sick and
uh high on nyquil is is to me that
you know that's like that's the proof of
what we're talking about so it's like
it's almost how in those high pressure
moments
that's when things seem to be the
calmest and the clearest
that to me is also a form of that
stillness
i agree but
doesn't it take stillness i'm using it
in a real simple sense of like
calm still and non non-reactive
open um
doesn't it take stillness to get to that
place though
otherwise you're operating from sort of
uh
you know sympathetic nervous system that
maybe doesn't
give you the best direction no i think
that's right you know like people
you know people think like hey the way
you become an nba champion is like
playing a lot of you know uh pickup
basketball games
and it's like no it was uh hundreds of
hours reviewing the playbook
you know it was hundreds of hours of
one-on-one drills
you know it's kobe bryant getting up at
4am and shooting
you know a thousand free throws you know
alone in the gym
you know a book is is hundreds of hours
of being alone by yourself
just working on this thing um
with no certain no certainty of payoff
you know what i mean so
so i do think solitude and silence and
self-control and sort of kind of a
bubble
all of that's required to ultimately
accumulate the knowledge and the insight
and the experience
so that you could be still while 200 000
people are
shouting your name while you're doing
this very difficult thing
um so yeah i think stillness begets
stillness
certainly yeah because it takes a
certain amount of stillness and quiet
to know what you want how many people do
you think
suffer from not actually knowing what
they want from life because they never
slow down enough to to know
oh i think i think that's mo that's most
people yeah like
that everyone i think has that voice
inside them that's talking to them
but most of us have way too much going
on to ever actually listen to it so
um what do you do i mean i live out in
the country
i uh i try to say no to most things i'm
very disciplined about routine and
schedule
um you know i think i think you've gotta
you've gotta carve out room for that
stuff to happen
um you've always done that not not
always
but you know i i um i
sort of when my first book came out uh
i and and it had done pretty well i
thought oh i'm a writer now
i must move to new york city
i moved to new york city and and in some
respects it was great for my career and
it was
exciting and fun and on the other it was
like
so immediately obvious to me that this
was not
a place where one could do important
work
personally or professionally because
there was
always not only was there always a
distraction
there was always a really good
distraction so
so it's like you know you need time like
not
doing anything and yet there was always
a dinner
always an event always a an
opportunity that it felt really foolish
to say no to
that living where i live now in texas
i don't even think about because i would
not get on a plane
to go do this um and so so i think
yeah you have to be saying no is really
really
difficult i have this uh
this someone gave me this uh do you know
do you know who jonathan fader is he's a
sports psychologist
he used to work for the mets um he works
with a lot of writers too he gave me
this
thing and so that's oliver sacks the um
the psychologist anyways it's a picture
of sax in his office and you can see
behind him
to feel like it was right here and it's
just a giant picture
a giant sign and it says capital n
o exclamation point and and it's
supposed to and i so i have it right on
my desk
right next to my desk the i actually
it's so i have a picture of my youngest
son
then i have the no thing and then i have
a picture of my oldest son
so it's sort of right between them the
idea being
um that you have to say no to all sorts
of extraneous irrelevant things
so you can say yes to the things that
that do matter and and so this idea of
being able to
to to choose what's essential or
separate the essential from the
inessential is really really important
it's like that takes some stillness but
then when you do it then you're able to
get stillness in the things that that
matter
what are the things that matter for you
the most or what what has come through
now to be the things that matter the
most to you
yeah so like you know people go like
what are your top priorities i've kind
of realized like i think if you're if
you're putting them in order
that's probably not the right way to
think about it but like for me it's like
uh my kids my marriage and then my
writing so like my sort of career
and then like the sort of two different
parts of my family which are the same
but also
you know different and so i i like when
i think about like where i want to be in
the future
it's not um like hey i want to have sold
this many books or i want to have
accomplished like
i think a lot of people have very
concrete goals
um which i think are good as far as
crystallizing like what you'll need to
do
to you know to to to accomplish it but
but i kind of think like no i want i
want
those things to continue to be
the highest priority in my life and i
want them to be
more or less unchanged you know so so
i've gotten to a place where i'm
much less concrete about my goals and
it's more about and this is obviously a
luxury of my profession
in that like you know writer you know
you you maybe have
a few seasons as a basketball player or
you know a few years as a racer
whereas like a writer you can do it sort
of until you die but
but my my thing is like i want to do
well at those three things uh
my whole life like so so that that's
kind of when i think about what matters
it's those three things
in some like i i the other way i think
about i've talked about this before but
i kind of think like what do i want a
day
in my life to look like and i kind of
back out from there
and it allows me to evaluate
opportunities
so someone came and said like hey i'll
give you
you know all this money to go do this
but then i would have to move here and
i'd have to show up at this office every
day
that would be really cool and it might
help me accomplish stuff but but
it would come at the expense of the
other things
yeah so would you say then that you're
getting happier
definitely yes and i think this
describe what happy's like then i want
i'm curious i asked that to be able to
ask you
what is happier like explain happier
yeah i mean look there's a certain
ineffableness to happiness
and i think unfortunately in western
culture we tend to associate
uh happiness with achievement yeah so
so um although i've seen interesting
studies there
they're looking at it like young people
tend to say
i feel happy when and then they fill in
the blank with like
i won this race or i got a quarter i got
this promoted
promotion but older people tend to
associate
happiness with feelings of contentment
like
and so so it strikes me if that's where
you're going to end up you should focus
on it now
um but but for me happiness weirdly it
comes
happiness and stillness feels at least
in
in the same ballpark to me like like
when i
when i don't feel pulled in a million
directions when i have
autonomy kind of over my life over what
i'm doing
when i when i'm sort of creatively
fulfilled
but but not like whipping myself so i i
i think for me
happiness feels like when i feel like i
am and i have enough um and and it's
when i'm
when i'm sort of yearning for something
or i'm chasing something
or i'm trying to get something back or
get rid of something
that's when that's when i'm feeling less
happy
so weirdly the last you know it again it
feels
terrible so i don't mean to be glib
about it but like the last you know
several months of this pandemic have
been an interesting trial for me because
so many of the things
that were part of my job and life
have kind of fallen away and so it's
forced me to sort of
reiterate and re-establish what those
priorities are
and then realize oh actually
focusing more on them is
just as rewarding personally and
professionally
as it is you know
leaping on all these opportunities that
come by
and and that and that there was actually
a hidden cost to saying yes to all the
things that i was saying yes to
so who taught us that all that is what
made us happy where does that come from
i mean to me that's like if you think
about
evolution what would be the number one
driver of like okay why does elon musk
start one company then start another and
then go
now i have to put people in space
right like that that i don't it doesn't
from what i
read and see i don't think i would want
to be elon musk
but i'm grateful that elon musk exists
so it's it's almost
like like his his inability to
feel enough drives the species forward
but comes at an immense cost to him
personally so
i think it shouldn't surprise us that
does it i mean does it
like that that is the question then if
you if you're grateful for him and the
progress that it makes our species make
but yet
less is more is kind of what you're
saying
it leads me to wonder what's the point
and why is there still a hook
that we need to evolve or do more or be
more like
why do we need that at all well i i i
think what i mean it's like from an evo
like like what makes somebody look out
over an ocean
and say i'm willing to risk death
never see my family again just to know
what's on the other side of this ocean
like we wouldn't be here in america if
people didn't have that impulse
and obviously there is you know a
historical
uh cost to that as well i mean but we
don't need to get into that
but but so it's like i under that that
spirit
of of of being unable to ever be
satisfied or sated
um there never is enough you never feel
good
from from a propelling the species
forward over
you know hundreds of thousands of years
that makes sense to me
but just because it's naturally true
doesn't mean
you know it's it's good for one person
so i but i think modern if you could do
it in moderation
maybe that's the best of both the
balance of all disciplines
exactly is that even possible
um you know maybe balance is a fleeting
thing
uh and and so it's about sort of trying
to get it
over and over again like you know what i
mean like i think
i agree a hundred percent i believe you
know let me talk about like
how to find balance in your life with
family and work and all these things and
i'm like
i don't think balance is a real thing i
don't think it's ever perfect
it's chasing the balance you're always
chasing you're like when you're at home
with your kids you're not working then
you go work and you will work and you
come home and then you
you know go play and have fun with your
friends but then you got to come home
and like
you're always chasing the balance yeah
yeah
it's like that moment of weightlessness
you're just getting the moments
of it or you know and then then you're
then gravity's pulling you right back
down and but you
you can still get it over and over and
over again
so what is the point of all this what is
the are you asking me what the meaning
of life is
yeah basically um i don't know i
probably should have
i probably should have just started with
that question because
i love to ask this question well so so
i i was giving you marcus realized his
answer earlier that sort of good
character
and and works for the common good i
think that's a pretty good answer
um have you read man search for meaning
the victor so it's an incredible book so
viktor frankl
is in three diff he's a psychologist a
jewish psychologist in vienna
and he's he spends time in three
different concentration camps
um he's sort of deeply inspired by stoke
floss he writes this book man search for
meaning which is one of the
best-selling books of all time it's
really an incredible document about sort
of human resilience and perseverance
but he's sort of saying that like
perhaps we think of like
we think that like we ask the question
and he's like maybe a better way to
think about it is like you're being
asked the question and you
answer it with the meaning you create in
your life
and so i kind of think like we're here
for this
sort of fleeting ephemeral moment
meaning is what we managed to cobble
together
through relationships through
the good that we do through the work
that we produce
you know through the the the sort of
collective
you know contributions we make to
humanity that's that's the meaning of
life what's your purpose
within this within that life
yeah i mean i i feel like that the sort
of three priorities i was giving you
the the sort of purpose is kind of a
triangulation of those things but i feel
like sort of professionally like what
gets me out of bed is
the idea of taking kind of
ancient wisdom and making it
accessible not just to other people
because obviously that's what i do that
like if i wasn't making it accessible to
people people wouldn't buy it and i
wouldn't
be able to publish books but i think
like
what i was doing this morning what was
got me excited this morning
was taking all these little bits of
things that um
that had uh i've read and all these
disparate things and they
they just kind of came together
magically this morning and i wasn't
it just that just gets me so excited
when like the
the dots line up and it works which is
probably
you know it's like probably that
giddiness you feel like when the race
starts or you find yourself in the
pocket or
you know your strategy is working
exactly you know when it's just like
it's working and so
yeah so i love that state
but i mean you could get it trading
stocks or
you know playing poker or something i'm
sure that's not really
what i like doing so for me it's it's
making connections you know from
history and psychology and philosophy
into
into something that works that's that's
what i love doing
what do you think the biggest lesson
that you've learned is through all of
your
reading learning and
sort of crossover between your own life
and application
yeah i don't know i don't know how you
would
i don't know how you would sort of
classify the size of it right so
i would say one of the ones that hit me
really hard so the stoics talk a lot
about death
you know they talk about this idea of
memento mori
did i'll send you one of these i i carry
this momentum more coin
but um the idea of meditating on your
mortality is a big one but
that i there was a a
passage in seneca that hit me in it i
think it's kind of changed how i think
about things and how i think about time
you know he says you know we think that
death is something that we're moving
towards like the death is in the future
so you know whether
per an actuary table you're gonna die
when you're 77
or like hey you know you have six months
to live because you have cancer whatever
it is like we think that death is
something we're
like death is stationary and we're
moving towards it
and he says actually death is happening
now he says all time passes belongs to
death
and i was like whoa okay what does that
mean um he's saying so like
every is his time that passes can't be
revised
revived and so his point was that that
it's not that like i've not i don't have
40 years
left it's that i've died 33 years
and um that was just sort of profoundly
eye-opening to me and then it goes like
oh like you know if
someone you know wastes five hours your
time
or whatever you know you just died five
hours and and that puts it all in
so so it to me it's really helpful as
far as like doing stuff that i don't
want to do
you know like when you realize what
you're paying for it
not what you're getting paid but what
you're paying it
it's very helpful well it's just boils
down to wasting time
yeah if you're gonna die in every moment
that you do something you better choose
to be living it
versus enduring it yes
totally and and so i yeah it's not like
people go oh okay so if you're gonna die
like
you know nothing matters it's it's not
it's that you could die
and so you have to live as if you could
die not
like if you would if you said yes
right like like if you knew it you were
going to die tomorrow
it would in a weird way probably make
everything meaningless
but if or you know what i mean but it's
like you could so you have to
make sure that you're doing everything
as if it
is the last thing that you're doing oh
that's like my
the perfect last question okay if you
had one more day then what would you do
with it
you know it's weird i don't know how
different
and and this probably sounds flip and
maybe people don't believe but i don't
think my day would be that different
than my ordinary day
okay so i wake up early i take my kids
for a walk
sometimes my wife comes sometimes she
doesn't uh i sit with the journal for a
few minutes
then you know sort of depending on
what's going on like
if i have to record stuff like i come to
my office but you know
so if it was my last day i probably
wouldn't waste time commuting or
something but
um uh i i write
like i spend a couple hours writing and
then i'm done and then i just
you know i just hang out the rest of the
day so you know we go in the pool or we
eat or we play games or whatever it is
like so so
that's kind of what my day is ordinarily
and and so when we're talking about
these
questions um philosophy is supposed to
help like
cicero you asked if philosophize is a
word
um cicero's famous quote is
that to philosophize is to learn how to
die
and so um and and then the idea is that
if you know how to die you know how to
live and so
i i do think if i had 24 hours left
i mean look i'd probably check my email
a little bit less you know
there's there's definitely things i
would do differently um
but the broad strokes of like
what i prioritize would remain
essentially unchanged and so i take some
pride in that
you should take a lot thank you
well i feel like you're uh you're living
your best life
and that's not something that everyone
can say yeah
it's it's definitely a a privileged
lucky place to be
and is supported in some you know
respects by external circumstances but
i'd like to think
i could get here with half the income
you know what i like i'd like you i'd
like to think that that that it it's
ideally it should not be dependent on
external circumstances or what good is
it
that's the goal it's not easy but that's
the goal yes
well thank you for helping us all figure
out how to get there
thanks for having me this was really
cool was it too intense
never or never you know i can probably
no i know i i didn't i didn't sugarcoat
nor did i try and
probe like i'm just that curious i i
could keep going on and on and on and on
because
you know i totally would love to riff on
death because i feel like i've been
reading about that a little bit too and
just how
you know thank god we die because if we
didn't die life would be meaningless
like death gives life purpose otherwise
what's a day
who cares yeah no exactly and
and most of the people that i know that
are really into the sort of radical life
extension stuff
can't really give you a good answer as
to why
yeah it's very strange we should talk
about death on my podcast
i'll have you on and we'll we'll just
talk about that
we'll live through talking about death
sounds good
okay thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button